l'invité de tir croisé ce soir c'est
françois bayrou le patron du modem
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être sur i télé
ce soir on n'en sait toujours pas plus
sur les propositions qu alexis tsipras
ce doit fournir à l'europe est ce que
vous pensez qu'il joue avec les nerfs de
ses partenaires européens où il a juste
du mal à boucler cet ensemble de
réformes qu'il doit proposer à l'union
il est le premier ministre grec dans une
situation qui est très difficile puisque
il a fait sa campagne électorale pour
être premier ministre sur le thème non à
l'austérité il a fait son référendum sur
le thème non à l'austérité
or il se trouve aujourd'hui dans
l'obligation de faire adopter un certain
nombre de mesures qui seront des mesures
sérieuses et qui forcément va être
interprétée par les grecs comme le
contraire de ce qu'il avait promis
donc il est dans une de ce point de vue
là une grave difficulté est autrement il
obtient ce qu'il a annoncé formellement
vouloir éviter c'est à dire la sortie de
l'euro et donc vous voyez à quel point
il ya une impasse dans la situation dans
laquelle il se trouve
mais vous pensez que concrètement il y
aura ces propositions il ya des
scénarios qui estime que voilà il
ils sont en train de les grecs seraient
en train de préparer activement leur
dépôt de bilan et en fait le retour à la
drachme vous y croyez ou pas c est
peut-être qu'ils sont peut-être
farfelues bon je crois à toutes les
hypothèses parce que ça fait quatre mois
qu'on nous annonce deux fois par semaine
le sommet de la dernière chance ça fait
quatre mois qu'on fait miroiter le fait
que la situation est en train de
s'arranger ou au contraire qu'elle
empire
en réalité il ya deux ou trois questions
qui se posent qui sont essentiels ya des
gens qui pensent qu'il est mieux pour la
grèce de sortir de l'euro valéry giscard
d'estaing était hier mon invité le
disais que je souhaite que on n'est pas
à vérifier cette hypothèse
parce que ce que je crois moi c'est rare
que je sois en désaccord avec valéry
giscard d'estaing
mais je crois moi que ça ferait un
épouvantable chaos en greffe les deux
noirs d'abord en grèce et ensuite en
europe parce que c'est la même maison et
on ne peut pas mettre le feu à une pièce
de la maison sans que le feu se
répandent d'une manière ou d'une autre
dans le reste de la maison et donc je
pense que ce serait un très grave
accident pour nous et un dramatique
accident pour les grecs et que cette
déstabilisation ce désordre
que signifierait la succession
d'événements qui qui seraient entraînés
par la sortie de l'euro serait une
catastrophe interne et externe donc si
j'avais le choix je souhaiterais qu'on
l'ait vite et deuxièmement on ne peut
l'éviter que si monsieur de sipera ce
décide au fond à aller assez largement
dans une direction différente de celle
qui l'avait promis et qu'il avait promis
encore huit jours et vous voyez à quel
point on est là devant une situation
tragique politiquement tragique pour
ceux qui ont joué avec la vérité que
pèse la france dans cette négociation
est ce que le tandem franco allemand a
tenu le choc selon vous et est ce que le
président françois hollande est à la
hauteur de la tâche qui lui incombe
est ce que le tandem franco-allemand
existe j'espère que oui il ne peut pas
en être autrement parce que l'allemagne
ne peut pas être en première ligne toute
seule et elle ne peut pas avoir un autre
interlocuteur que nous dans la zone euro
un interlocuteur qui équilibre ou qui
paraissent équilibrés ses choix
deuxièmement est-ce que
la chancelière allemande et le président
de la république française savaient
exactement où ils vont moi j'ai des
points d'interrogation à cette question
on sait qu'ils ne le savent pas je pense
que monsieur chat ou bleu est très ferme
je pense que revêt la merkel ne veut pas
apparaître comme la responsable de
l'échec et je pense que françois
hollande joue un double jeu qui est un
jeu de politique européenne en même
temps qu'un jeu de politique intérieure
c'est à dire qu'il essaie de rester le
plus proche possible de la gauche de la
gauche tout en ne se coupant pas de ses
partenaires européens
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce qui me
frappe le plus françois hollande ne
s'adresse pas aux français on est on est
dans une période de crise aiguë la plus
grave crise que l'union européenne et la
zone euro aient rencontré depuis leur
création
on est dans un moment où tous les
européens et tous les citoyens français
s'inquiètent et à juste titre et que dit
le président de la république rien qui
soit audible par les français il aurait
dû venir sur un plateau comme le vôtre
ou vous inviter à l'elysée pour
simplement s'expliquer devant les
français de ce qu'il perçoit des risques
et des chances et de la ligne qu'il va
suivre
s'il l'avait fait il aurait marqué de
son empreinte les négociations
européennes
il ne l'a pas fait et à mon sens pour
moi il est il n'est pas en phase avec ce
que la fonction présidentielle exige la
fonction présidentielle et d'une
certaine manière
une fonction de guide pour les citoyens
une fonction d'orientation pour les
citoyens et si vous ne leur parlez pas
il ya peu de chances que vous les auriez
entier est ce que le couple
franco-allemand connaîtra des lendemains
difficiles
après cette crise quelle qu'en soit
l'issue non je pense que le couple
franco-allemand et condamnés à
s'entendre
en tout cas condamné à travailler
ensemble au pilotage de l'union
européenne alors l'un apparaît comme
très fort du
du point de vue commercial industriel et
budgétaires l'autre apparaît comme
faibles et faible est un mot prudent du
point de vue commercial
notre commerce extérieur s'effondre du
point de vue budgétaire et de points de
vue industriel tout le monde le sait
voit en tout cas dans des secteurs assez
large
évidemment ça ne fait pas un couple
équilibré nous voudrions que ce soit un
couple équilibré mais ils sont condamnés
obligés de vivre et travailler en ce
sens nous sommes responsables français
et allemands condamnés et obliger à
travailler ensemble
vous êtes plutôt pessimiste donc sur la
conclusion d'un accord entre aujourd'hui
et dimanche avec le sommet des 28 chefs
d'état
si nous étions responsables les
dirigeants européens et les dirigeants
grecs on éviterait la sortie de l'euro
si nous étions solides on se dirait
voyons on est une union
il ya des pays qui est en grave
difficulté comment faire pour le sauver
qu'il retrouve un équilibre qu'il
n'entraîne pas le reste de notre de
notre équipe vers la chute je crois
qu'on pourrait y arriver
rien n'est impossible dans cette affaire
on peut d'abord allonger la durée de
remboursement de la dette sans supprimer
la dette
et vous voyez qu'il ya une nuance entre
les deux on peut rendre à la grèce des
instruments essentiels qui lui manque
cadastre par exemple il n'ya pas de
cadastre en grèce or nous nous savons
dessiner un cadastre en quelques mois
puisque la des satellites qui permettent
de repérer chaque parcelle et l'état
grec peut intervenir une fiscalité qui
soit à peu près solide et qui
réussissent à recueillir l'impôt qui
n'arrivent pas à recueillir aujourd'hui
une tentative pour exclure les paiements
en liquide ce qui permettrait de faire
rentrer des taxes vous voyez que tout ça
n'est pas au delà des forces humaines
mais ça signifie de la volonté des deux
côtés et une entente qui pour l'instant
n'existe pas
un mot de la loi macro qui a été adopté
cet après midi de façon définitive par
l'assemblée après un 3e 49 3 c'est une
loi qui va dans le bon sens
est-ce que les quatre mois de
d'embrouillamini autour de cette loi en
valait la peine
c'est une loi qui va petitement dans le
bon sens c'est une loi qui va à petit
pas dans une direction qu'on devrait
approuver mais ce qui est choquant dans
le loir macron et tout le monde le voit
c'est qu'il ait fallu quatre mois des
centaines d'heures de débats pour
adopter ce qui pour l'essentiel est un
catalogue de petites mesures ce qui
prouve que nos institutions et nos
institutions parlementaires en
particulier sont complètement inadaptés
à des décisions rapides et fortes comme
il faut les prendre et le débat lui même
est un jeu de postures
vous avez vu l'opposition s'opposer à
des mesures qu'en fait elle réclamait ce
nancy aujourd'hui simplement parce que
c'était l'autre camp et il ya même des
responsables de l'opposition qui ont
fait 2 du vote de la censure contre un
texte qu'ils approuvaient un élément de
vos fonds de positionnement tout ça
évidemment c'est complètement dépassé ça
n'a pas de sens
tout le monde voit que ça n'est pas un
véritable débat et de véritables
décisions qui sont prises et c'est un
symptôme de plus au fond de l'épuisement
de nos institutions
votre débat extrêmement important
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée au sénat c'est
celui qui concerne l'orientation
budgétaire
évidemment est ce que la france fait
assez en matière de réduction des
déficits publics alors tout de votre
réponse à la question vrai c'est est ce
qu'il y as que la france respecte les
orientations qu'elle se donne
si si on regardait le la réalité des
chiffres et la courbe de ces chiffres on
s'apercevrait qu'il n'y a pas de
véritable amélioration de la situation
budgétaire de la france
si l'on reprend les promesses
présidentielles au moment de l'élection
de 2012 s'était d'ailleurs les mêmes
qu'en 2007 dans des camps différents on
s'apercevrait qu'on a promis juré craché
que l'on reviendrait au dessous de 3%
dès 2015 ou dès 2016 qui évidemment il
n'en sera rien on avait promis qu on
descendrait très au dessous de 4%
on est à plus de 4% la dette de la
france continue à s'alourdir de même de
manière extrêmement rapide et tout ça
vous le voyez bien c'est un signe où on
signe parle à l'impuissance publique
française
l'impuissance politique française des
majorités successives qui se font élire
sur des promesses péremptoire et qui
dans la réalité ne changent pas grand
chose ce qui au fond entraîne
le fait que le pays s'enfonce dans une
lente et parfois accéléré récession
enfin chute qui au travers du temps marc
notre échec collectif
un dernier mot françois bayrou sur cet
appel qui a déjà été signée par un
certain nombre de personnalités dont
nicolas sarkozy publiée par valeurs
actuelles pour un appel à ne pas
transformer les églises en mots ce
qu'est ce que c'est un appel qui a du
sens selon vos pas bon il ya eu une
phrase malheureuse et dalil boubekeur
que j'ai moi-même condamné sur laquelle
je me suis moi-même exprimer et c'est
une phrase qui évidemment symboliquement
était de la nitroglycérine
et pour moi il n'est même pas imaginable
composent cette question de cette
manière là je crois que l'auteur de la
phrase monsieur boubakeur a retiré cette
phrase s'est exprimé est ce qu'il est
vraiment besoin de relancer le sujet
pour en faire encore une fois un point
où on essaye de faire flamber un certain
nombre de ressentiment et de passion
s'ils ont été raisonnables on ne le
ferait pas si on s'intéressait à l'unité
du pays on ne le ferait pas d'un pays
qui a besoin qu'on défende clairement
calmement son identité ce qu'il est et
au fond le fait qu' on veut la paix
civile chez nous vous ne l'ignorez pas
donc je ne signe russie très rarement
des appels jamais de pétitions j'essaie
d'être le plus clair possible j'en ai
signé une sur la réforme du collège
parce que j'avais été de ceux qui l'ont
écrite
merci beaucoup françois bayrou d'être
venu ce soir sur i télé pour nous parler
de la grèce et de la politique française